thank you alejandro lev first of all
welcome to the studio i think if i'm not
mistaken this is the first time that
you're coming to the studio visiting us
in this tournament
maybe second time second time yes second
time it is now you are playing a second
match also against ray robson you won
that first match in the playoffs how did
you approach this second match knowing
that you were going to play 25 minutes
plus 10 a different time control
um
since
the last match i think uh
it was going smoothly
i thought that i should try to
do the same you know surprise my
opponent early on in the opening
and then try to press on the clock tell
us a little bit about this idea d3 e3 f4
we've never seen anything of that nature
previously how did you find this idea
um
yeah i was looking at it
early in the morning and i thought uh
in a rapid game this could be a
an interesting option because well i'm
basically waiting for him to bring his
knight to c6 and take it
and play e4
and the way he played it actually
reminded me of some kind of uh
sicilian uh russolimos with e6 where
you're also trying to get the same
position
uh and
yeah i think it my preparation kind of
worked because uh ray spent a long time
thinking
and uh he didn't really play the best
possible moves it also reminded us if he
doesn't take on e3 then you go e4 maybe
e5 of your game against wesley so
yesterday with reverse scholars did it
give you any flashbacks of that
ah no not really
but
yeah sometimes i do have that threat as
well of course it's a typical threat for
this type of positions
yeah
the fact is that since i'm white i can
afford to play like that you know
because
if i was playing with black you know
losing so many tempest in the opening
it's normally not a good idea but here
at least uh i'm posing some practical
problems without revealing too much how
much theory did you know up to which
point
did you know this g4 idea no i didn't
really look at the techie
uh
yeah i thought bishop e7 is the right
move
and yeah there are many ideas in this of
course and after it suck yeah i thought
here i felt for some time i thought the
how can i develop properly because i
don't want to put my knight on e2
because it allows e5 fe knight g4
even if it doesn't allow it and i don't
want to play knight f3 because of knight
c6 and then
e5 knight g4 as well
and then i thought started thinking to
myself what kind of move yasser would
never play
and
then the right solution came to my mind
g4 is very strong because it stops c5 i
have f5 and i create the same blockade
but it also has to be coupled with this
idea of giving up the light square
bishop with bishop takes c6
another move probably that yasser
wouldn't play
but it did seem like this was actually
the best move uh in the position why
don't you feel like you're taking full
control of the game
yeah here i thought that my position is
so good that if i
you know don't blunder anything massive
uh i will probably slowly win the game
maybe i didn't play my best moves but
the position is so unpleasant that i i'm
you know with the extra time i'll put up
a block blocker on f4 and just
push yeah slowly
and so
yeah more or less i was not really
looking for the best moves but i was
trying just
to you know keep the control of the
position and then uh
when i saw this uh a3
trapping the rook idea then i thought
okay
if i i would fall for it with black so
yeah
so you saw it from before you played the
move a3 provoking the move a5 and now
knight takes
idea
very nice i take c5 and yeah this is
just over yeah yeah i mean it's clear
that black is not in time to create any
serious counterplay
great well first of all uh nice to have
you for these
memorable interviews that we can't
remember when you were last on our show
lavonne
once again i mean now you've got some
experience under your belt
another similar question you've already
answered about the format uh you've
played more matches uh you know what
it's like with your back to the wall and
the different time controls how is the
format treating you you feel like
it's fun are you having fun
when you win the answer is yes by the
way
uh i think it's uh you know
one problem with uh knockouts is
when uh you're losing the game you're
extremely sad yeah here at least uh you
get the second chance so right i think
this is a this is a great format it's
it's a lot of fun because uh for us it's
been a great pleasure not just calling
your games but all the games in fact
they're the they're full of fight and
tension and the no draw
and also i think the majority of chess
players love playing rapid
yes yes yeah you know when we're
thinking about playing a classical game
and it's kind of a bit of a you know
torture at times if if you were to lose
the game uh to lose the match and just
continue playing another classical match
that would be a bit of a torture right
but here you lose and you get rewarded
yeah
well good you've got one more game of
course in front of you thank you so much
for joining us
always a pleasure
indeed thank you lavon and certainly